so it's only recently dawned on me that
I have never made a video covering the
Sator the Greek spirits of nature and
fertility I have previously discussed
the god Pan but never the satyr
themselves so if you like creepy old
goat men I guess this videos for you
the ancient Greeks referred to the satyr
as either satyros or Sailor knows which
is quite similar to the Roman satyr I
but no doubt the Roman name that most of
you'll be familiar with is of course
faun now where most people seem to get
confused is that they believe the word
faun is merely the Roman name for a
satyr which isn't true satyrs and fauns
do have some similarities but for the
most part they are a different set of
creatures in terms of both appearance
and personality and there is this
misconception that both forms and satyrs
are half-man half-goat creatures but
some of the earliest accounts of satyrs
are closer to wild man than mythical
creature
they were often depicted as short
balding wild men with a horse's tail and
a constant erection hence the
association to fertility forms on the
other hand were always depicted as
half-man half-goat and despite being
feared by those who traveled in the wild
they were actually said to help
travelers who had become lost satyrs
mostly just tried to have sex with
nymphs and drink as much wine as they
could thorns for the most part were
jovial and mild tempered creatures but
they were also quite naive and foolish
whereas satyrs were far less helpful and
far more ill-tempered
the forms have pretty much mr. Tumnus
before he became professor Eck's and
satyrs are that weird uncle that no one
really wants to be around but you have
to say hi anyway because it's Christmas
a time for family and togetherness that
and your parents threatened to take away
all of your presence if you didn't make
conversation but they'll just take those
presents away anyway because apparently
you were a poorly behaved child who
climbed Christmas trees and threw
ashtrays at people but those are just
lies and slander so the very obvious
lesson of today's video is never listen
to your parents they're stupid and you
always know what's best if you want to
climb a Christmas tree because you think
Santa is at the very top then you climb
your way to the North Pole if you want
to throw ashtrays at your younger
cousins because they told your mum you
were climbing the Christmas tree then
you throw as many as you can get your
grubby little hands on and if you want
to make a video about the Sator you
should probably stick to the script and
not go off on a random tangent about
Christmas stories that no one really
cares about in June but hey the only
time I can record videos is at 3:00 a.m.
so leave me alone now we mentioned
earlier that the Roman thorn was not the
same as the satyr but that's not to say
that the faun wasn't influenced by the
satyr and that's because there are many
different types of satyr throughout
Greek mythology not just the creepy
uncle archetype the biggest influence of
the faun was probably the pan airs which
as you may have gathered from their name
were the children of the god Pan who did
have the torso of a man and the hooves
of a goat closer resembling the half-man
half-goat aesthetic that we've become
accustomed to some even had the head of
a goat and virtually no human qualities
these panels were obviously closely
linked to pan whereas the satyr we
mentioned earlier were the followers of
Dionysus in the epic poem dionyza
Kharitonov
the panas were monks the satyr that
followed Dionysus in his expedition and
war with India
another type of satyr were the Solano's
the children of Salinas and the mountain
limps responsible for protecting
Dionysus as a child and due to their
father's association with wine and they
were also considered spirits of
winemaking
no pun intended they also appeared
similar to the original satyr old fat
men with a boarding head and a horse's
tail sometimes their bodies were even
covered in white fluffy hair making it
almost impossible to take them seriously
the whole association to wine and women
means they were often celebrated in line
of Dionysus and during these festivals
it wasn't too uncommon for people to
dress up as satyrs and perform some kind
of play so on to some of the more famous
satyrs and what better place to start
them with Salinas and el de satyr born
from the earth with a father never
mentioned we can look at a gaya as one
of these satyrs main origins Salinas was
considered the first god of wine a
mantle that he would later passed down
to Dionysus and that's because he was
essentially he's foster father who along
with the nymphs of Mount Nyssa would
raise him from just the baby he then did
what every good father does and taught
Dionysus the value and importance of
alcohol so I guess we know where he's
party going attitude came from overall
Salinas is depicted as a jolly old man
who likes nothing more than having a
good time with his favorite drinking
partner and stepson he was also the
catalyst behind the story of King Midas
as him and Dionysus were separated
during what I guess we can assume was a
drunken night out
he then woke up lost in the kingdom of
King Midas who recognized him and
offered the satyr his hospitality when
the two were finally reunited though
Isis granted the king he's golden touch
and we all know how that story ends
the most well-known Sater is undoubtably
pan the god of shepherds hunters music
and the wild amongst many other things
not every poet seems to agree on his
parentage but more often than not you'll
see him considered as the son of Hermes
and Penelope but this can also range
from Zeus to any number of nymphs found
in Arcadia
just like Salinas pan was also thought
to be an elder satyr but despite this he
doesn't have many children we would
recognize by name instead he's just
credited as the father of his kind
the name pan is thought of as one of the
origins for the word panic and that's
because pan was said to have a scream
that when heard Maties enemies panic and
run in fear this is something he used
when the Giants invaded Olympus and even
when he accompanied Dionysus in India
it's also a pretty fair assumption that
this may have been where the Roman idea
forms being feared came from pan as
we've just mentioned is no stranger to
conflict in one of the stories of Zeus
and - when - defeated Zeus he took from
him his tendons and sinews leaving him
wounded and incapable of fighting back
when all of the other gods and goddesses
had fled in fear it then felt a pan and
Hermes to retrieve these tendons and so
they did Zeus would then go on to defeat
- and crush the Titan rebellion once and
for all we can't really mention pan and
not discuss his association to music and
the creation of the pan flute in this
story he fell in love with a nymph named
sy rinks and he planned to tell her how
he felt when she returned home but when
she did and pan approached her she
didn't know pan merely wanted to pay her
compliment and so she ran away as fast
as she could she ran to her sisters who
then transformed her into a reed found
in the water so pan wouldn't recognize
her and this worked as the wind blew
into the reeds pan notice that they made
a pleasant melody
not knowing which one of the reeds was
his beloved nymph pan took a handful and
placed them together and when he blew
into them he created the first pan flute
dedicated to the love that he had lost
it was fairly common for the satyr to be
shown chasing nymphs and pan himself
does this quite often funnily enough
it's not even the first time a nymph
transformed herself into a random object
to get away a nymph named pities
transformed herself into a Pinetree when
she was pursued often throughout Greek
mythology there are certain individuals
or creatures who dislike each other with
the satyr it's hard to say because they
spend most of their time listening to
music and drinking wine I guess you
could argue that they weren't
particularly fond of the Giants but
almost everyone hated or had some kind
of issue of the Giants so that isn't
really saying a whole lot the giant with
100 eyes Argos Penna POTUS had a brief
altercation where he killed several
satyr but in this story he was helping
the people of Arcadia because the satyr
was stealing their cattle when Zeus went
to war with the Giants the satyr war
among the many who offered their
assistance riding into battle on their
donkeys and no I didn't just make that
up
they actually rode donkeys all the time
maybe they were that drunk that they
thought they were horses or maybe they
were just that short they couldn't ride
horses regardless the image of a short
drunk man riding a donkey makes me think
of a dwarf and in some aspects the
personality of the satyr
and dwarves are quite similar but where
dwarves prefer to live underground in
their forges making awesome weaponry and
treasures the satyr prefer to run around
the forest in their weird drunken orgies
overall satyr was seen as woodland
spirits associated with fertility but
the term itself is fairly broad because
they can differ so drastically not only
in terms of appearance but also
temperament for example you have the
dwarf like winemaking satyr you have the
half-man half-goat children of pan and
you even have satyr who are described as
nothing more than pan flute
players so essentially the musical satyr
we have this bunch of somewhat rowdy
creatures that most of the time just
wanna sing dance and drink which pretty
much just describes the human race
nowadays they've become somewhat of a
staple in modern fantasy but when it
comes to stories aimed at a younger
audience more often than not you'll see
them as forms because their
personalities are more in line with
something for a younger audience now of
course that isn't always the case
the four nin Pan's Labyrinth is far from
a jovial looking creature granted that
movie isn't exactly made for children we
also can't forget the 1997 Hercules
movie by Disney and they just completely
ignore the faun approach as we see a
satyr named Phil and he does demonstrate
very satyr like behavior with a desire
for both wine and women but there was
this weird mix between a satyr and the
hero Philoctetes hence the name Phil but
I don't really know where Disney was
going with this one but that doesn't
matter because Phil is voiced by Danny
DeVito who is not only the greatest
actor of his generation but of this
entire universe so if you've ever
wondered what a satyr or a faun sounds
like the answer is obviously the trash
man and the trash man I come out I think
fresh all over all over the ring if you
do have any thoughts or questions on the
satyr then feel free to leave those in
the comments below as always I've been
your host mythology in fiction explained